Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's den Klassiker, nämlich frittierte Donuts!
Das hört sich immer so Abturner-mäßig an wenn jemand sagt "frittiert",
aber bei Donuts bin ich echt ein Fan vom Frittieren, das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen!
(H: Warum denn Abturner?)
Ist einfach so! Weil man denkt Oah, fettig und so...
(H: Aber Kiki, die Leute gehen ja trotzdem draußen Donuts essen!)
Auf jeden Fall! Und das komische ist: Wenn ich die z.B. selber frittiere,
dann wird mir bewusst: "Ja ok, es ist frittiert"
aber wenn ich die dann draußen esse,
(H: Dann merkt man das nicht!)
Dann merkt man's auch nicht!
(H: Deswegen versteh ich das manchmal nicht!)
Ich auch nicht.
Also haben wir das auch schonmal geklärt hier. Direkt, direkt hier ein Statement
direkt rausgehauen!
(H: Also bitte gleich nicht sagen: "Öh, ist das frittiert, ist das voller Fett?)
Genau!
(H: Ihr müsst das nicht machen!)
Genau. Weil: Donuts meiner Meinung nach sollten auch frittiert sein.
Es gibt natürlich mit Sicherheit eine gesündere Variante.
Wenn ihr möchtet, dann zeig' ich euch die auch. Dann mach ich sie vielleicht mal im Backofen,
schreibt mir das einfach hier unten in die Kommentare,
(H: Ja, auch ne gute Idee!)
aber heute gibt's die klassischen, wie bei Dunkin Donuts!
So! Haben wir's!
Und jetzt zeig ich euch hier direkt die Zutaten für den Donut Teig, das ist immer ein klassischer Hefeteig.
Und da hab ich jetzt mein Mehl in meiner großen Glasschüssel der Küchenmaschine,
ihr könnt das auch mit den Händen kneten.
Und was ich euch jetzt hier direkt an Tipps geben kann:
Ich leg direkt los, ich hab hier ein bisschen Mehl, also 50g Mehl
hab ich hier zur Seite gelegt.
Das geb ich noch nicht rein, es kommt nämlich auf die Größe oder auf das Volumen der Eier an,
wie viel Mehl hier im Endeffekt reinkommt.
500g sind hier schon in meiner Schüssel, wie gesagt 50 einmal an die Seite legen.
Jetzt mach ich hier so ne kleine Mulde direkt in der Schüssel,
geb da die Milch rein, ganz wichtig: die muss lauwarm sein, die darf aber auch nicht
über 40 Grad sein, 38 Grad wär perfekt.
Und dann einmal in die Mitte der Mulde reingeben.
Und da bröseln wir die frische Hefe mit hinein. Ihr könnt auch Trockenhefe nehmen,
schreib ich euch alles in die Videobeschreibung!
Und dann auch noch so ungefähr 2TL Zucker als Nahrung für die Hefe.
So, und jetzt zugedeckt 10min ruhen lassen.
So, 10min später, da durfte jetzt die Hefe schön arbeiten
und ich hab auch extra nur ein bisschen Zucker dazugegeben.
Im Rezept haben wir insgesamt ein bisschen mehr Zucker, aber wir wollen die Hefe ja nicht
im Zucker "ertränken" quasi,
daher reichte das jetzt definitiv aus.
Und jetzt geb ich alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu
und knete das heute mal in der Küchenmaschine mit dem Knethaken.
Ihr könnt ja wie ich grad schon erwähnt habe auch eure Hände benutzen,
mach ich auch ganz gerne bei Hefeteig!
So, jetzt haben wir einmal Zucker,
(H: Bevor die Hefe nen Zuckerschock bekommt, ne?)
Jaa! Dann haben wir hier Butter, ganz wichtig: schmelzt sie und lasst sie auskühlen,
die darf nicht heiß sein! Geb ich hier auch noch mit dazu.
Jetzt kommen alle Zutaten, zeig ich euch jetzt nach und nach.
Und wie gesagt: immer bei mir immer in der Videobeschreibung, ganz easy!
Und dann hab ich hier 2 Eier, die sollten auch auf Zimmertemperatur sein,
also nicht ganz frisch aus dem Kühlschrank, das wär ideal.
So, jetzt werdet ihr euch wundern: "Hä? Salz?"
Doch, Salz! Und diesmal auch viel, nicht nur eine Prise wie ihr es sonst kennt von mir,
sondern einen gestrichenen Teelöffel. Das zeig ich euch,
das ist ungefähr so viel. Das sind 4g, die kommen auch da rein.
(H: Kiki benutzt einfach ihr Cakeboard..)
als Spiegel!
Mega praktisch, ne? 2 in 1!
(H: Du hast jetzt deine Haare..)
Ich hab heute einfach nur einen Bad Hair Day! Es ist so wie es ist, deswegen hab ich sie jetzt zugebunden.
Passt ja auch ganz gut, denn jetzt knete ich meinen Hefeteig per Hand weiter,
weil dann könnt ihr entscheiden wie viel Mehl da noch reingehört.
Ich hab da jetzt grad schon so ein bisschen Mehl reingegeben.
Wichtig ist halt, dass der nicht mehr kleben darf und der muss so ein bisschen Widerstand noch haben,
der darf auch nicht zu fest sein. Aber das zeig ich euch gleich am besten.
So, jetzt hab ich den Teig 2-3min lang weitergeknetet und der ist jetzt so perfekt!
Also ihr drückt rein und der gibt so ein bisschen Widerstand und so muss er auch sein.
Und es ist echt so, dass ihr manchmal 530g Mehl braucht, manchmal 550g,
da müsst ihr einfach selber schauen und nach Gefühl arbeiten.
Und jetzt geb ich hier ein bisschen Backtrennspray auf den Boden meiner Schüssel,
die braucht ihr auch nicht auswaschen.
Wieso ich jetzt kein Mehl dazugeb, das hat einfach folgenden Grund:
ich möchte nicht, dass der Teig unnötig austrocknet weil gleich beim Ausrollen
geb ich auch nochmal Mehl dazu.
Und deswegen möchte ich hier beim Aufgehen kein Mehl dazu geben
und geb jetzt gern das Backtrennspray oben drauf noch
damit das nicht austrocknet.
Und jetzt zugedeckt 45min lang ruhen lassen bis sich der Teig verdoppelt.
So ihr Lieben, nach der Ruhzeit ist der Teig deutlich aufgegangen.
Und ich nehm mir jetzt die saubere Arbeitsfläche, geb da etwas Mehl drunter
und geb den Teig obendrauf.
Diesmal nehm ich meine Ausrollstäbchen, die sind hier 10cm dick
und das mach ich bei diesem Rezept aus dem Grund, damit ich weiß:
"Ok, die werden alle gleich groß, sie sehen alle gleich aus, die brauchen auch gleich
lang im Fett."Und deswegen hab ich sie eben so ausgerollt.
Und  jetzt nehmt ihr euch 2 runde Ausstecher oder z.B. auch ne Tasse oder was auch immer ihr da habt.
So ungefähr 8 bis 8 ½cm sollte dann euer Donut groß sein.
Ihr könnt auch Mini Donuts machen, das ist auch euch überlassen.
Ich mach heut die klassischen.
Und innen das sind glaub ich so 2 ½cm.
Und ich stech jetzt einfach mal ein paar Donuts aus und leg sie dann
auf die bemehlte Arbeitsfläche und bedeck sie dann direkt mit nem sauberen Küchentuch.
Den ausgestochenen Donut Teig jetzt nochmal 30-45min lang abgedeckt gehen lassen.
Wenn ihr 45min Zeit habt, dann nehmt euch die Zeit gerne
weil in der Zeit geht es nochmal auf und das bewirkt eben,
dass sie so schön fluffig werden.
Und anschließend einfach Frittierfett erhitzen.
Entweder nehmt ihr euch einen tiefen Topf oder einen breiten Topf
oder eine tiefe und breite Pfanne, so hab ich das heute gemacht.
Und heute nehm ich Distelöl, das ist bestens geeignet zum Frittieren.
Ansonsten geht denk ich auch Rapsöl, schaut auf jeden Fall, ob's zum Frittieren geeignet ist
und es muss halt eben geschmacksneutral sein, das ist ganz klar.
Und jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig: Wie lange muss ich das frittieren?
Es ist echt immer unterschiedlich, selbst bei mir jetzt.
Also die ersten haben glaub ich 1 ½min gebraucht, dann
die anderen waren nach ner Minute schon fertig.
Ihr müsst immer schauen, ich zeig euch jetzt hier auch mal Beispiele.
Die hier sind nen Ticken zu dunkel gewesen. Es kommt auch wirklich
auf 2, 3 Sekunden an, ne?
Und den perfekten Donut hab ich hier. Kannst vielleicht auch mal scharf stellen, dass man das...
Also das ist meiner Meinung nach der perfekte Donut. Schön hell, nicht zu dunkel.
Das Öl darf eben nicht zu heiß sein, dass das Fett eben nicht den Donut verbrennt.
Es darf nicht zu kalt sein damit der Hefeteig das Ganze nicht einzieht.
Und was wir auch gezeigt haben: Du hast wahrscheinlich die Stäbchenprobe schön aufgenommen, Hamza?
Das heißt tut einfach einen Schaschlik Spieß in euer Öl und wenn
ganz langsam Blasen aufsteigen, dann ist es perfekt.
Und die Temperatur müsst ihr halten. Immer mal niedriger stellen, mal höher.
Ich hab jetzt immer Stufe 5 und 6 genommen.
Und dann sind wir eigentlich auch schon fertig. Jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Schokoladenguss, ne?
(H: Darauf freu ich mich schon!)
Ja, ich mich auch! Dann wollen wir mal!
Ganz klassisch ist ja Vollmilch Glasur. Dafür nehmt ihr am besten temperierte Schokolade.
Das macht ihr folgendermaßen ganz easy:
Ihr nehmt euch ein Wasserbad, das heißt einfach ein bisschen Wasser im Topf aufkochen lassen,
eine feuerfeste Schüssel obendrauf geben, damit die euch auch nicht kaputt geht.
Da gebt ihr dann 2/3 eurer Kuvertüre rein. Ich nehme natürlich Vollmilchkuvertüre.
Ihr könnt auch Zartbitter oder weiße nehmen.
Das lasst ihr dann schmelzen. Sobald es geschmolzen ist, einfach vom Topf herunternehmen,
dann das restliche Drittel dazu geben, in der Resthitze schmelzen lassen
und zack, habt ihr die perfekte temperierte Schokolade bzw. Kuvertüre!
Kein Grauschleier, die glänzt wunderbar, da muss kein Fett oder sowas rein.
Und wir können anfangen, die Oberfläche der Donuts einfach da rein zu tunken.
Ich nehm mir jetzt einfach mal einen, tunk den hier kurz zur Hälfte rein,
lasse ihn gut abtropfen, dann lasse ich das auch nochmal aushärten.
Ohhh! Perfekt!
Und ihr könnt noch bunte Donuts machen, beim Kindergeburtstag z.B. blaue, pinke,
lilane, grüne - alles was ihr möchtet!
Und was ich mir überlegt hab: schnappt euch doch gerne Candy Melts!
Die hab ich auch im Shop, verlink ich euch genauso wie alles andere unten in die Infobox.
Und die nehm ich jetzt weil weiße Schokolade ist eher beige statt weiß.
Und Candy Melts sind eben weiß. Mich fragen ganz ganz viele: wie kriege ich weiße Schokolade hin?
Fast unmöglich aber nehmt dann die Candy Melts. Einmal reintun, ich schmelz
das Ganze jetzt gleich in der Mikrowelle.
Und dann hab ich mir überlegt geb ich da noch bunte Streusel oben drauf.
Und dann einfach mal schauen wie's optisch aussieht,
also ihr könnt da ganz wild rumexperimentieren!
So, jetzt wünsch ich euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken der Donuts,
die exakt wie bei Dunkin Donuts schmecken!
Aber es gibt natürlich ganz, ganz viele Varianten.
Es gibt ja Oreo Donuts, dann gibt's gefüllte Donuts...was magst du am liebsten?
(H: Gefüllte!)
Mit?
Irgendwas mit Vanille bestimmt!
(H: Auf jeden Fall!)
Vanillepudding, Vanillecreme...
(H: Dieses Boston Cream!)
Boston Cream! Oh mein Gott! Wir müssen unbedingt mal Donut Rezepte machen,
also schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, was nicht fehlen darf!
Also dann zeig ich euch auch die Füllung und das Äußere und alles drum und dran!
Wusaaa! Ganz ruhig Kiki!
Auf jeden Fall wünsch ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken!
Die schmecken wirklich unglaublich lecker!
Die Glasur ist jetzt noch nicht ganz eingezogen, ich gönn mir gleich auf jeden Fall ein paar.
Kannst auch gerne probieren wenn du möchtest!
(H: Ein paar?)
Ja natürlich! Ich mach mir doch nicht die Mühe damit ich nur einen einzigen esse und dann
"Mh, ja ich bin satt!" Nein! Det gibt's bei mir nicht!
Wir probieren am besten gleich. Wir probieren auf Instagram, ok?
(H: Auf jeden Fall!)
Wenn ihr uns auf Instagram noch nicht folgt, ganz dringend einmal nachholen!
Dann seht ihr dann immer Teaser, was es bei uns so gibt.
Und ansonsten wünsch ich euch - zum dritten Mal sag ich's ja schon - ganz viel Freude!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal! Ciao!
Boah!
Ich weiß man lobt sich selber nicht. Das macht man nicht.
Irgendwie gehört sich das nicht.
Aber ganz ehrlich: die schmecken besser als bei Dunkin Donuts!
Die schmecken einfach nur so gut!
Unbedingt nachmachen!
Wer das nicht nachmacht, ist selber schuld!